as I'm sure many of you watching this
video will already be aware
sadly the great Stanley has passed away
most of you probably don't know but this
channel predominantly started as a comic
book Swan before turning to movies and
TV and I can't really emphasize enough
how much Stan's imagination and
creativity has played a huge part in my
life when I was younger I was absolutely
obsessed with spider-man and he was kind
of my gateway into comics as a whole I
remember playing the PlayStation
spider-man game and being completely
swept in by the narrator of it who I
later found out to be Stanley Stan came
across as someone who was in his
mid-twenties even though he was in his
90s his passion drive and enthusiasm for
all his projects made him a joy to watch
and like many Marvel fans I always look
forward to his appearances in the Marvel
superhero movies this was a man who had
a huge influence on pop culture that
cannot really be understated he was
pretty much responsible for the way that
all movies TVs and games a day are and
everyone at some point seems to have
taking something from him Stan worked
until the day he died and now I never
met him the footage that I saw of him
made me really believe that he was one
of the good guys
Stan beamed hopefulness and pretty much
embodied the morals of the characters
that he created he was a shining beacon
of light in a bleak time and it's no
surprise to see all of the tributes
pouring in from across the globe I
wouldn't normally do a video on
someone's death but I think his passing
is the perfect opportunity to remember
the incredible kind of generous life
that he lived Stan was ultimately and
forever will be the king of comic books
and I don't see how anyone could replace
him the fact that he created countless
characters that all went on to become
huge successes as a testament to just
how much of a genius he was it's gone to
be sad seeing Stan pop up in Marvel
movies for many years to come but it
also highlights the legacy that he left
behind Stan was a man always seemed to
have time for everyone and no doubt he
will leave behind a huge hole in their
lives of everyone and that he had a
positive impact
don't rest in peace Stanley
you